gossin Abdul Idris is a man with a
mission to end child marriage and he's
doing it with the one thing he has at
his disposal his voice
[Music]
gossin has experienced firsthand the
institution which he hopes himself to
end the was no clear kerosene
Hanazawa JK no vodka what I can when you
win a Tyrian FF Erin Leigh has a clear
we are mobile services alele Yanni
videos order and that's the phone and Co
philosophy as well met the child
marriage puts women at a particular
disadvantage because they are often
removed from school with four children
three of them daughters gossin works to
educate men and women in his community
against this practice gossin hosts talks
he speaks with men about the
disadvantages of keeping girls out of
school he talks about allowing kids to
be kids muhammad al-baqir we had a
memoir Latinas SATA Smith whom
additionally shudder to be hopefully
which was in the ejector auerbach digit
excel how does develop you know to some
selfie to show a job
Deshmukh Shannon is and head of men
highest gross motor your foot grown out
earlier to an outer we don't actually
amber urinal Allah was tough and it
works
many people have changed their minds
being exposed to these new ideas has had
a positive effect hello
da-da-da-da-da coalition led by Lana
Lana Fifi JV football and Ferguson it
all comes back to family and to his
daughters and I was she with my uncle
Danny when I am she was the dalai lama
and in Harlan was a hired anomaly keeps
ugly baited with Tim is attacked and
made them what a sentiment in damage
fear at work a lot animal industry
[Music]